but uh bringing this up we i have a uh i
think one of the most important stories
proud boys black lives matter leaders
meet to denounce white supremacy
and it looks like we have uh two proud
boys as well as a black woman with a
black lives matter shirt on and i'm not
entirely sure
it looks like one of the proud boys is
white but the other uh appears to be
uh non-white of some sort i i really
hate that they've racialized everything
i hate that i have to bring it up i have
to talk about it it really is
frustrating and annoying and absurd
but i think it's important to point this
story out this is from 17 news my
stateline.com
they say salt lake city leaders of a
local chapter of both proud boys and
black lives matter met
to denounce white supremacy last week
after they were mentioned at the first
presidential presidential debate
the proud voice said their safety is
threatened when people believe they are
white supremacists
quote i will go out and say that the
proud boys as a whole
i will say this on behalf of the entire
national organization denounce white
supremacy
the chief of the s of the proud boys
salt lake utah chapter
who only gave the name thad said fox 13
reported
we are in no way shape or form white
supremacists we have a vetting system
that gets those people out of our hair
we do not have anything to do with white
supremacy we don't have anything to do
with the ku klux klan
we denounce those organizations then we
have appears up
another quote from proud boys met with
jakari kelly the leader of black lives
matter northern utah
which is not affiliated with black lives
matter utah saying i had no idea who the
proud boys were
i heard the words proud boys mentioned
throughout the activist community
and i just didn't know who they were and
then i started to hear they were white
supremacists
kelly met with thaad and proud boys
chapter president seth to discuss
myths about both groups we came to
realize we had more in common than not
in order to combat evil and racism and
hatred in this country
we do need to be able to reach across
the aisle and have these tough
conversations that everybody is scared
to have
kelly said the proud boys she met are
not white supremacists and said they
were proud american men
who needed a little bit of respect and
education in order to bridge the gaps
i don't care what color your skin is
we're all americans and we need to find
a way to come together instead of divide
said seth
thad however singled out antifa which
biden called an idea
and not an organization at the debate
saying they are a problem they are not
they are not an idea they are very much
an organization they are in terrorist
cells
that's why they say they are not an
organization they function autonomously
in cells much like terrorists according
to kutv
thaad said the splc and the adl along
with mainstream media had created a
misconception about the group
blaming violence that has taken place at
certain proud boys events on
provocations by antifa
they're going to mention uh you know
where where the
the problems were found with kevin
mcguinness and i just want to uh point
out
that uh to hear a a black lives matter
uh
leader saying i don't know this group is
i'm gonna meet with them and then saying
no they just need
some education in some respect but
they're proud american men i think
really uh shows the media is
constructing much of the narrative
if you're if you're gonna have a black
lives matter leader actually come out
and vouch for you guys i think that's
powerful but more importantly we saw
something interesting as thaad calls out
antifa i think this is important
just the other day a black lives matter
activist
ratted on antifa antifa was planning
a flash mob in i believe was portland
and a black lives matter activist said
stop using black lives matter to
disguise your activism
and apparently alerted the police who as
soon as the group formed within minutes
surrounded them on all sides and
arrested every single one of them so
this is antifa
getting arrested essentially because
black lives matter tipped them off
i wonder if the real problem in this
country is the far left provocateurs and
extremists
who who are attacking trump supporters
conservatives who are essentially
acting with impunity when these da's
just cut them loose across the country
and we've seen numerous videos where
black lives matter activists call them
out there was one where some black women
were yelling
at some white antifa women who are spray
painting and then you have these white
women saying oh no we're doing it for
you but they're damaging
you know the black community i guess i
bring all this up because uh following
the story i'm curious what your thoughts
are on black lives matter
especially in contact in this context
and with antifa
there's some overlap between the riots
with black lives matter and antifa as
well
so i was i was actually gonna make a
press release before
um i came on the show last week about
this
i haven't spoken about this and this is
actually the first time i'm gonna speak
about this
but our uh our salt lake chapter was uh
has been in talks right with trying to
like make amends with certain groups
and um jakari uh
met with thad and they had private
conversations and they
uh he called me and he's like hey i'm
doing this and this is something that i
think is
uh important we're not we're clashing a
lot but i think
we could make amends somehow
so after our 26 rally i actually
took some time out of our festivities
that night
to meet with jakari and um it started
out as a very volatile situation
where we didn't agree with each other at
all but there was something in common
that we had
and before i say that um i think
the blm movement right
the premise that it was started on on
police brutality i think is something
that
everybody should vibe with yep i think
police brutality
is bad period it's not something that
our group
focuses on as much but we respect that
other groups are focused on that
um but there is some
overlapping things that both groups have
right
um two of our tenants which should be
i i feel like they should be
conservative values but
usually they're not portrayed that way
is the closure of private prisons
i was in prison for some time for a
white-collar crime
i deserved all 10 months of what i got
and another thing is the failed drug war
and we both groups at least at that
point we could disagree on
everything else and we do we do because
it was a very
again it was a very volatile situation
in the beginning
but we got past it and i've been on the
legislative side of things for
for a little bit of time um
so the first step was getting together
and making those amends
and so after that meeting they met a
couple of more times um
and they actually had a press conference
they had nothing to do with the debate
at all this was already this was this
was already planned
and uh i know that we're we were gonna
catch crap
by both sides we always catch crap from
the left but we knew we're gonna catch
crap for
for working with blm but it's beyond
that there's something wrong with the
judicial system in this country
and our guys i feel strongly that our
guys in new york got the short end of
the
the shaft there and it's because of that
broken system so
our next phase is working together on
getting some type of
something passed through the legislator
on something that we disagree on
and that's imagine as a legislator
even like a freshman legislator you got
the proud boys and blm
walk in and they come together and they
want to
present something that is either
anti-drug war
or towards private prisons uh something
that's pro-liberty
so that's why we met and we feel like
bridging that gap is important when
needed and
their movement has also been co-opted by
anarcho-communists that aren't there for
george floyd that aren't there for
uh briana taylor that aren't there for
any of those
they're just there to crash this system
they're there they think they're
role-playing these revolutionaries and
i'm here to tell you right now
those people antifa they're victims
they're victims to a system that has
failed them they're victims to a media
that has told them to hate people
because of
of their values to me white pride groups
right they're prideful of things you get
me you ask them hey how do you feel
about black and brown people and they're
like oh well i hate them
you have to ask me hey i denounce all
those things
but go ahead and ask them to denounce
communism and they'll
they embrace it i mean i love it i can't
get uh
i've asked some of my staunch you know
pro-biden
friends i shouldn't say probably
anti-trump is probably a better way to
put it denounce antifa they won't
they literally won't do it it's the
weirdest thing to me
and this and i think this is a a big
indicator of something
you know happening in this country i
don't know if donald trump's going to
win i think there's a lot of reasons to
think he will the data is completely
against him
but there's a group of people in this
country former liberals politically
homeless
who have absolutely no problem saying
white supremacy is horrifying
evil wrong should be denounced totally
beyond totally just get rid of all of it
and antifa is bad too because they're
violent authoritarians who go around
burning down people's buildings
why is it so difficult for people on the
left who are voting against trump to
denounce antifa
i don't know i don't i wish i had a
clear answer to that but they've created
this system they've they've made them
their foot soldiers
you get me i think
they've taken so long to do it that even
uh don lemon
the other day called him out on it
because of the polls he saw the poll
numbers and he's like well democrats
aren't doing good these riots i mean the
two biggest things that were going on
in the country this past year besides
all the craziness that 2020 has brought
is covid and riots right and democrats
imagine you're a business owner
i'm a i've been a small business owner
my entire life
imagine that you get shut down for three
months
while walmart amazon all these major
corporations are making
billions and your little coffee shop
gets shut down
and you're in the middle of
portland i love going back to portland
because it's like
the epicenter of this and they go ahead
and
and they shut you down the city
government shuts you down you have no
way of putting food on the table
[Music]
democrats are taking forever to sign
like these uh
these uh what's it called the stimulus
things
um and then you're finally able to open
up you're in phase two you're opening up
you're doing ubereats
and then here comes antifa and they
go ahead and they throw a molotov
cocktail through your window and burn
down the entire thing
like how are you gonna feel you're gonna
feel like
sorry yes it's one you're gonna feel
like you're gonna feel like crap because
you everything that you've worked for
and they tell me oh well you you think
of
property before people that's somebody's
sweat and tears that's food on the table
for your kids
right that's that's your future you're
building a future for your family
and somebody comes and the government
comes and takes it away from you and
then this anarcho-communist group takes
it away from you
and that's why i think trump's gonna win
i think trump's going to win
because he's been calling out these
shutdowns he's been calling out these
riots since day one
we've been screaming about it for four
and a half years
we said it's gonna ramp up we said that
they're gonna get worse
so here's here's the important
distinction i'll make now with uh as it
pertains to anti-fun black lives matter
the overlap
these extremists these are
anarcho-communists i wouldn't i don't i
don't think it's fair to call them an
arc communists i think they're
authoritarian communists and archer
communists
they're seizing the anarchy they're
taking advantage of it but i think they
do want authority
i think anybody who's willing to use
violence to get what they want is an
authoritarian who'll retain that use of
that power because they never feel they
won
that's like a common theme with these
people they're like if only i can just
win then i'll make everything right they
use violence they win and they say well
we're not done with the mission yet
we've gotta and so they do these things
but one thing i've said often is that i
don't like calling the rioters antifa
because they're flying black lives
matter flags now you've mentioned
they've co-opted it
yes but then they do attract a lot of
people who are not communists who are
just racial justice activists
who fly the flag of black lives matter
for black lives matter
but they've been radicalized or brought
in by you know revolutionary communist
types
so confusing yeah definitely
it's so confusing yeah the black lives
matter and antifa kind of just
escalated together with the covet thing
and then everybody started losing their
jobs and people still went out on the
street first thing they did was like
loot buildings and to take things that
they couldn't afford
that's not necessary or things that they
have always wanted like people walking
out with [ __ ] boxes of shoes they were
there was like one video of someone
carrying one
shoe yeah it's not about wanting booting
it was about coming up making money
yeah well they did it in miami they hit
like the like the highest like
mall that they had there and they like
pulled out like
a whole bunch of like gucci bags and
jordans and
and i don't know how that honors
like you're out there for george floyd
and racial justice i mean how how does
that
even begin to honor the system and as a
matter of fact they're making it worse
the defund the police thing they're
making it work
it's like they're training them to to
to quell protests like they're they're
basically they're giving them free
training to do this
and just imagine now here's here's
another thing you could imagine so
imagine you're a portland police officer
you're sitting there with like a hundred
pounds of gear on you
right you got no days off like today's a
riot so you can't take the day off
and your buddies are lined up and these
people this
this green-haired whale is like
screaming at you
right and uh some other dudes like
throwing water at you
and pointing lasers in your eyes and
then your buddy next to you
he gets hit with a molotov cocktail
which almost happened
it gets hit with a molotov cocktail you
got to turn off your buddy
the night shifts over these the the
riots have have quelled i don't know
where they go
um they probably go under the bridge or
something but these riots have quelled
and then you're in the locker room
right you're in the locker room at the
police station and you're taking off all
this gear and your buddy's there he's
burnt all over the place
and what do you think that they just
created they created probably the
strongest brotherhood
that you could imagine like these two
guys
right here that stood next to each other
like they're gonna they're gonna ride
together
you know and they they're creating this
this system
that's already there they're creating
this system that's going to be really
volatile
if it continues to progress they're not
defunding the police
they're arming them absolutely that that
connection
is even worse than militarizing police
well i think they're uh arming them is
the correct way to phrase it i've warned
about this so long as the far left keeps
going out smashing windows with impunity
amer the american people are going to
keep asking for more law and order more
powers for the police more powers for
the federal government
and we're trying to get to a point where
we have you know officer friendly back
we don't want we don't i don't want cops
to feel like they're going to get shot i
don't want them to feel like they need
an armored vehicle but
it's gotten to that point because the
far left escalates goes crazy and so i
had an interesting conversation actually
on this show with some of the super
chats saying
you know how would you envision
demilitarization what does that mean
what
what weapons do they use are militarized
and i think the issue is just this uh
you know as i said you've got these
officers they wear this full on tactical
armor often
they're you know it's camo gear so it
looks like they're in the army they've
got rifles
or it looks like they're in some kind of
combat situation they have armored
vehicles they ride around on
and it doesn't look like officer
friendly and the response i got was
if antifa is shooting people if they're
throwing molotovs or
throwing bricks and riders are doing
this don't the officers need to protect
themselves
and the answer is yes so then it seems
like there is no
real reasonable way to you know
demilitarize as many left-wing activists
say i still think that we can uh
i think we need more funding for police
i think defund is the wrong thing
i think if they want social workers and
they want better trained community
policing
they need more money the cops need
better pay the cops need better training
the cops need to feel valued and what
they're doing is the opposite of that
so they're making angry cops they're
they're making cops demand more
protective gear and more
more uh weapons more techniques team
sport
but more importantly there may it's not
you tell the story of these two cops
you know they come in the locker room
they're taking their gear off and then
the one guy says together i'm like i saw
that woman screaming your face dude he's
like i know and then
they kind of chuckle it's all over then
they go home to their wives
and their kids and he sits down on the
couch and he's like what happened at
work
some ladies screaming on my face these
auntie foot people are crazy the wife
gets angry and she's like i can't
believe they would do this to you
the kids hear it the kids get mad they
tell their friends
antifa is spreading hate you know these
cops are people they have families they
have friends they go to the bar they
talk
people hear these things people care
about them antifa showing up and doing
everything you said spinning on them
splashing on being nasty being awful
it's spreading hatred now i understand
there are some bad cops and there's
police brutality
and these we have laws for that they go
to jail i do believe that we've got
police culture problems because i've
personally experienced
an officer lying under oath to try and
convict falsely convict somebody
hopefully uh
um thankfully i had footage proving the
cop lie there was no there was no
penalty for the cop who lied
so i'm i think we need reforms i think
we need to make sure we get justice when
police commit crimes like perjury or
literal crimes murder or otherwise and i
think
cops need to be better funded better
trained and we need i i like the idea of
some kind of social worker that the the
the you know the defund the police
people have brought up but they're going
in the wrong direction with it
they're saying defund the police take
that money and hire social workers
and i'm like but then you have you know
a vulnerability that
social worker can't handle every
situation a cop can keep the same amount
of cops
send a social worker with them for
certain situations and that social
worker can deal with
certain issues because we have seen
positive results but taking money away
from the police just makes everything
more tense more dangerous
increases anxiety you end up in new york
where you've got a billion dollars
slashed off the nypd budget murder
skyrocketing shootings
lethal crime yep so thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you